members when i invite you to speak there
are microphones around the table on
on which you're you're sitting please
wait until you have one of the
microphones in front of you before
speaking
all microphones are switched on
ready for you to speak
so you don't need to adjust them
however can i ask you to speak clearly
and directly into the microphone when i
invite you to speak
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the constitution i
will ask for a show of hands for and
then against and recommendations and
would also ask for a show of hands for
those wishing to abstain
from voting
has it helped
yes it is
agenda items one and two apologies for
absences and substitutes
we have received apologies for absence
from councillor grips who will be
substituted by councillor sharp
welcome
apologies have also been received from
councillor constable and councillor
myers will be substituting thank you
very much
agenda item three non-members attending
uh councillor james gooding councillor
julie gooding and councillor gaston
no he's sobbing
minutes of the meeting held on the 24th
of may are there member minutes agreed
members
thank you
declaration of interest free item five
members the applications relating to
items 10 and 11 of the agenda are
submitted by gb partnerships on assets
owned by rdc as part of a development
contract
this is legally acceptable in planning
terms if granted the council will have
the benefit of planning permission and
therefore members of the develop
development committee will have an
other pecuniary interest
okay
as a result the monitoring office
officer has granted dispensation with
effect from the 21st of june
2022 which is in effect for one year in
line with the provisions of section 33
of the localism act 2011
so that members are available to vote on
applications
members items eight and nine of the
agenda are applications might made by
one of our councillors
we all have a non-pecuniary interest in
those items so nobody needs to declare
stick their hands up or anything okay
that makes it a lot easier thank you
members
are there any
uh any other declarations of interest
please members
no can't see any thank you
item addendum six
cloverly chelmsford road roareth
mike's strengths will present the
officer's report thank you mike
thank you chairman
um
this application is to a site
edged as you see here um the chelmsford
road a 1245 to the west the junction of
roars lane with that at the bottom of
the screen and you see the housing in
bedlows avenue and also front in rorth
lane and members will be familiar i
think with a number of different uses up
this side of the road and to the to the
north of the site
um if we could see the existing plan
please on the site in better detail
we see these collection of buildings in
industrial use on this part of the site
we're looking at this part which you'll
see at the moment is is development free
the buildings on there
are varying in size
um but you'll see they're contained by
surrounding build development if we
could jump to plan three please
the proposal before you tonight
is these industrial units and compounds
each compound has a building within it
and the details of those are set out in
the report
and you'll see that these sort of
landscapes bund at the end of the site
and to the
south it was like a
small seawall type raised ground with
planting on it as a legacy of other
stuff i think that's gone on the site
but you'll see it doesn't include that
it includes this sort of flattish area
in the middle between that and the
existing buildings
the proposal
is for those units to be used for
industrial purposes in what is now used
class g the former industrial b1 use
that you'll be familiar with
and you'll see there's also car parking
provided here to this end and around the
adjoining
middle buildings
and the compound would become enclosed
by a 2.5 metre high palace eyed fencing
and if we can see the elevations of the
typical buildings please you'll see the
single story low rise
pitch roof forms
flexible space and again the sizes of
those
are set out in the report most of them
10 of them are the same smaller size uh
the two in the middle are slightly
larger in floor space and because
they're a greater width they're slightly
higher in in span
um the site is within the metropolitan
green belt where development like this
is usually inappropriate
but if we can jump to the clovelly
aerial please
members will remember that the national
planning policy framework
allows for what they term infilling
and you'll see from the report that
officers are supportive of this normally
anywhere else in the green belt usually
we'd say well it's inappropriate and i
dare say the applicants wouldn't even
bother applying but the government's
approach is where you have this like
settlements
and there's these like infill plots here
and we pointed out the landscaping at
the beginning of the site gives us what
we call a defensible boundary
in this case um
it's worthy of approval the government
policy would support the development
being approved because you're in filling
in what is an existing uh settlement
pattern
so having satisfied the test of
appropriateness
you'll see from the report there's also
an economic argument where the existing
activity on the site that proprietors
have owned that wish to expand and
you've got general policies in your
development management plan that support
existing policies
sorry existing premises to expand and
businesses be that by way of extension
or as in this case
further development
so based on that chairman uh it's
appropriate in the green belt it
supports an existing business and the
recommendation is there for approval
subject to the conditions that are set
out in the report
thank you mike
there's one public speaker for this item
ian coward planning agent um
can i ask you to sit on the corner so
everyone can hear you and we'll get a
mic for you
you will have five minutes and i'll let
you know when one minute to go okay but
we'll just get your mic
okay thank you thank you good evening uh
as introduced i'm the planning agent
the site at cloverley works caters for
an important sector in the business
world and has done for many years
successfully among the current tenants
we've got contractors kitchen fitters
car storage and a stone mason
now these are all businesses which
reflect entrepreneurial local people
and as such they make an important
contribution to the economy
it's been estimated that over 80 people
are currently employed by the
pre-existing compounds and that's been
the long-standing position
the sites fall to capacity and there is
a waiting list and there's ongoing
inquiries people are constantly asking
if their space and being put on a
waiting list as explained the
application seeks an eastwood extension
to provide for for so to provide for 12
more compounds and as a rough tally
that's 100 new jobs give or take
as part of the process of going through
the the consideration of this
application we met with your officers in
economic regeneration and they very much
welcomed this proposal and explained
that such applications are in fact rare
and it is of course not just the large
multinational businesses that need to be
catered for the best economic
contribution is made by providing space
for a mix of different businesses
the site is in the green belt and your
office has set out a detailed assessment
of the relevant policy in support of the
positive recommendation which of course
we welcome
we start with it being limited infilling
within the village and so appropriate
within the green belt as has been
explained we're not seeking to develop
the whole site but instead of creating a
soft eastern side and are infilling
between the large nursery buildings to
the north and the residential to the
south your officers have also set out
the economic case very special
circumstances which is also part of
green belt policy
no technical objection to the proposal
we've covered drainage in detail and we
know that the parish were concerned
about this at one point
there are no other objections i've not
seen any concerns expressed by local
residents so this is clearly not a
proposal which is seen to be
controversial locally and to be fair we
anticipate that many would like to see
the economic opportunities being
delivered on this discrete and
well-defined site within the village
and for all of those reasons we welcome
the support of members thank you very
much thank you very much
the world members are well the only one
we've got here is uh councillor stanley
would you like to speak you have five
minutes
thank you
thank you
um
he's
greatly appreciated in the area um now
i've got a couple of things i want to
ask the planner uh if it's possible to
put these on as conditions
um
an acoustic barrier
for
uh to along at least the site at the
back side of the uh
uh residential gardens
um
i feel that we need to do something like
that for the noise from these 12 units
that are going to be there and i'd like
to propose that
please
and also
what drainage has been
put in place
do we have uh a pond or something like
that to an attenuation pond for for the
drainage as that would be a considerable
amount of concrete going in that area
these are
just two of the things that i would like
to answers to please
thank you cancer stanley
uh mike strengths would you like uh
true advice please
dealing with the drainage first you'll
see condition seven of the
recommendation actually asks for uh
specific details on this matter to be
submitted so i doubt there's a need to
duplicate that with a further condition
the case office is already ahead of you
on that
and what would happen is the applicants
would submit those details for the
detailed assessment um with regard to
the acoustic barrier
um there has to be justification for the
the conditions that you that you put on
and this is uh the new use class e which
would cover
what we used to call in the trade the
the
light industrial
those uses that are usually
uh comfortable adjoining um residential
properties
as opposed to general industrial like
the car repairs and the metal bashing
and the noisy stuff so as it's of a
if i call it a light industrial
uh type use to
um to help the discussion although
really the word light industrial is out
of fashion now
um
you'd struggle perhaps to impose this on
the applicant which would be an expense
that they would probably quite fairly
argue is unnecessary given the nature of
the types of uses that are there so it's
not a condition chairman that i would
recommend that we put on for this
particular
uh nature of the use if it had been a
general industrial use we would have
probably and the applicants themselves
would have probably put it in like the
one we've had in weight crim where there
was a waste transfer site i think in
places like that but as this is meant to
be
as sort of neighbor friendly as
industrial uses get
um personally i don't think that i'd
recommend you to to go that route
because i think it's over and above
what's necessary to make the application
acceptable
they're going to be used for and if they
are used for any any anything that makes
a noise in the way of generators and
such like i think the the uh a
acoustic barrier should should be should
be put in there or something towards
that too so people can use their gardens
saturday afternoon or saturdays and
sundays not necessarily during the week
but they are a lot of retired people on
that bedlows estate
and that's my concern is that they are
retired and they do use their garden so
i think an acoustic barrier would go
down really well with that and i would
like to put that as a motion forward
please
yep that might look kind of how that
might come back please thank you
chairman perhaps i didn't make myself
clear condition 10 of the recommendation
limits the use to the light
i keep using the term but the light
industrial type uses
so if they were to
make use of the premises for the noisier
types what were the b2s and so forth
then they were in breach of their
consent
so with that condition on if members
support that condition condition 10
should they be minded to approve it
my point is you wouldn't need to go the
extra mile to get the acoustic fence but
if if the operators come along later
maybe sometime in the future and said
you know we really need to adapt these
uses and make them industrial heavy
industrial or whatever
that would require planning commission
because of this condition and then i
think would be the time to consider the
acoustic uh protection because it
perhaps be warranted as members are
saying
because of the nature of the use this is
the more neighbor friendly type uses
and therefore my advice to you is that
it's going it's putting the applicant to
an added expense unnecessarily if they
were to stick with the scope of the
consent that we're recommending
thank you very much
members does that any other members want
to debate on this please counsellor mrs
mason
again you have five minutes
thank you chair
just a really simple question of the
officer if we could have the other slide
back please it shows the aerial view
with the
that's it
thank you and and i'm sure this has been
covered but i've read it a few times and
i've read it before
and having seen that slide i'd just like
some reassurance one of the things
that we want to protect on greenbelt is
the openness
now this
plot as far as i can see
has a very dense hedgerow around it
which will shield very nicely
the buildings however the
plan would
seem to
include removal of that now i know that
we've got a management plan on item five
and there's another one on i think item
nine but can i just ask if
the existing hedgerow which obviously
will protect that site exceptionally
well if that is to be retained
thank you chairman
hopefully members can see that the the
buffer that i think is being referred to
is being retained
in the scheme and i believe there's a
condition that i can't in a red mist
find it that um argues for its retention
and protection by way of the consent so
hopefully that's that's far enough that
we need um to give members peace of mind
it's on page 6.3
that was whether she applied to that
area or not okay thank you that answers
my question i've got no further
questions thank you very much any other
members
no
right members
no
i'm not sure
there's a motion on the table members
for approval can i please have
a show of hands for
approval and please keep them up
until sonia says
lower them for approval members
it's unanimous members thank you very
much
and you can lower your hands obviously
item seven
it's the arterial park chelmsford road
katie rogers will present the officer
are you okay to do this yes
sorry
members this application relates to a
site formerly known as michelin's farm
at the junction of the a1 sorry
the a127 um here and the a1
two four five
the site to which the application
relates is edged red but for the benefit
of anybody who can't distinguish that
and that's along this boundary the
northern boundary extends along here
along the bank of the railway embankment
and then extends south along the western
boundary
and then east along here
south again um east um just about a
butting the a127 here on the southern
boundary and then up northwards um and
just in this irregular shape here up
again to the northern boundary there so
it's this part of the site that the
application before you tonight relates
phase one of the site which is that part
edged blue um towards the east so this
area here
adjacent to the a1245
has recently been developed and two
buildings subdivided into commercial
units now occupy this part of the site
a new vehicular access at this point
here in the northeastern corner
is now operational
so this application relates to the
remainder of the site which is allocated
for employment use and this part of the
site already benefits from outline
planning permission
for employment uses within the general
industrial office and storage and
distribution use classes
this application before members tonight
seeks approval for reserved matters
relating to access layout scale
appearance and landscaping and it's the
acceptability of these matters only that
can be considered when determining this
application tonight
so the plan now on screen is the site
layout plan um and this shows the
footprint of the proposed buildings in
blue so this one here
one here one here and an elongated
building here so there's four buildings
proposed um again these these will be
accessed by the existing
or the newly created uh vehicular access
point here
and which also serves phase one
unit 10 the largest proposed building
will be site is closest to the this part
of the southern boundary here
um and we would feature a series of
docking stations here for hgvs to access
from the proposed service yard which
would be in this area of the site here
to the east
car parking for employees and visitors
will be provided adjacent to this unit
to the north
unit 11 would be orientated such that
the rear elevation
would extend adjacent to another part of
the southern boundary of the site with
the associated service and delivery yard
for this unit
just to the north of it and the
associated car parking here to the east
of that unit
some disabled bays i should mention are
provided throughout the park in layout
as are electric vehicle charging points
serving some of the bays
unit 12 would similarly provided with a
yard for hgv movements and a car parking
area
and then the elongated building along
the northern boundary adjacent sorry
adjacent to the northern boundary would
be subdivided into seven units of
differing size each with an enclosed
yard and parking off the main access
route through the site and just to the
south
the main road through the site would
feature
a formal pedestrian footwear so along
here there's an existing footwear in
phase one and that would extend across
this road
and then along this southern boundary
and around this corner and then a foot
way provided to part here and part of
this
um boundary here too
a pedestrian only point of access um to
the site would also be proposed here on
the southern boundary and this will be
adjacent to the pedestrian-only point of
access that's in this vicinity for phase
one as well
the only vehicular access to the site is
via this newly created vehicle access
onto the a125
the units are designed with large
warehouse spaces of significant internal
height alongside much smaller office
space provided over two or three floors
these internal office spaces are shown
in rectangles on this plan so you can
just see that that area of unit 10 would
be office accommodation this area of
unit 11 this area of unit 12 and then
the small elements in in the other units
and to the top as well
the original outline application allows
for buildings sorry the original outline
consent allows for buildings within
office general industrial and storage
and distribution uses which this
proposal would be consistent with what i
have is some 3d visual image images
which i think are helpful um to give
members an impression of the
um the scale the external appearance and
the materials that would be used in the
construction and the form of the
buildings as well
so in terms of appearance the buildings
would be similar in scale form and
external facing materials to those
already constructed in phase one
this is an image of unit 10
which i've just pointed out on the
layout plan so this is the largest unit
proposed on the site and you'll see just
along this elevation here that the
proposed service yard and image of that
and then this is the surface car parking
for employees and visitors
there's another
image
here
so this is
looking west um so this is um the second
largest unit proposed in phase two unit
11 and this is unit 12.
what's not shown is that elongated
building along the northern boundary but
it is similar in design and form and
appearance to these other buildings
shown
the finals um
3d image
gives an impression of the overall site
so this this includes phase one which is
already constructed and now operational
so phase one is this here so these two
buildings with the service yard in
between
and what we're looking at here is
largest unit 10 unit 11 12 and then this
building which is along the the northern
boundary of the railway embankment
i also have some photos just to show
members um the phase one
um so you can see this is actually
what's been built this is the the first
image shows the corner of one of the
buildings on phase one the type and
color of cladding and glazing around the
main entrance here and that's where the
office accommodation is provided in that
corner of the building
in the second image
you can see
the car parking that's proposed in front
of the units and the large sort of
docking um sort of
loading bay doors for hdvs
members will note from the signage and
virtual activity that a number of the
units within phase one are now occupied
and members will have noted on the
addendum that there are two consultation
responses recently received from
occupiers of phase one um commenting on
the um
value of this new business park
employment site the high quality
accommodation that's been delivered and
the good transport links associated with
this site
and the last two photos
are probably of use to any members who
haven't visited the site although many
of you have and have been inside some of
these units
this one shows how um the internal space
can be used for storage so stacked
space although there's only one floor
the significant height allows for that
to be used successfully for storage and
distribution uses
um and then just the final photograph of
existing on phase one shows the
alternative so it allows for um sort of
perhaps more b2 type uses to be um
facilitated in these units and so this
is like home car repairs
and then this internally is the office
space that's sort of um
first floor and above
so very similar layout of the floor
space is proposed within the buildings
on phase two
just close those
so landscaping is another of the matters
to be determined in this reserve matters
application and soft landscaping as you
can see from the plan on screen is
proposed within the site along parts of
the site boundary in particular so along
this northern boundary here the western
boundary here
internally as well with some tree
planting
alongside the access roads
within the site
in addition
in terms of landscaping the developer is
proposing a an area of external seating
to be used for employees to provide
somewhere for them to take a break
from work and some benches and seating
will be proposed there and we have a
plan just indicating that so that will
be provided in this area here and it
will be adjacent to the main footway so
available for
employees of all of the units on the
site rather than just i'm designated to
one specific unit if i just scroll down
on that plan
you can just see a small layout here of
of some benches and hard landscaping
sort of paving and then some some
planting around that as well
so just take you back to the master plan
the site layout
members will note that the application
does not include the land to the
southwest corner so this part here which
is allocated for gypsy and traveler
accommodation
the proposed site layout includes the
provision of a road so all the way up to
a point on the boundary with this um
adjacent allocation
which would enable
future and vehicular access to that
allocation if needed
we have taken into account potential
impacts on the gypsy and travellers site
should it be developed so members will
note there are a few conditions
recommended so windows in this elevation
here at first floor will be required to
be obscure glazed so we're just
protecting those future residential
amenities
and we've also restricted
openings in terms of doors
in particular on these elevations here
in terms of noise transfer
to that gypsy and traveller allocation
the council's allocation plan policies
relating to both the employment land
allocation which is this here and the
gypsy and traveller allocation
require the need for a substantial green
buffer between these two uses
and some soft landscaping would be
provided within the site here along this
boundary here
but the developer is also going to be
required to provide some landscaping
including tree planting
within the gypsy and traveler allocation
and that will be of benefit in terms of
newly planted trees being having more
time to establish
to provide a greater visual buffer for
taking into account future development
possibilities of that gypsum traveller
site
another key consideration is andwood
lodge so there is one residential
property that borders this site and
that's in this location here just
adjacent to the southern boundary
officers have been careful to consider
the proposed layout and scale of
particular unit 10 here
in relation to the impacts on this
residential dwelling and although unit
10 is substantial in height and scale it
would not extend directly adjacent to
the rear garden boundary so the rear
garden boundary of this dwelling is this
area here and so unit 10 has been
positioned over to the west so it
wouldn't be directly behind
noise from vehicle movements in the
service yard associated with the unit 10
so that's in this area of the site here
would be appropriately mitigated by a
five meter high acoustic fence so that
if you can see the light would extend
down from that southeastern corner of
unit 10 all the way along
to meet the eastern boundary there
in conclusion officers consider that the
proposal is acceptable with regard to
the reserve matters that are for
consideration
the proposed access arrangements would
be acceptable with no
objection raised by the highway
authority
the scale layout and appearance of the
proposed buildings would be acceptable
taking into account the context of the
site and it is considered that
appropriate mitigation would be secured
to protect the amenity of existing
occupants of anward lodge and future
occupants of the adjacent gypsy and
traveller site
the recommendation that chairman is
therefore one of approval subject to the
conditions
as stated in the published report and as
amended are set out on the addendum
in addition two very minor further
changes are recommended to conditions
five and six that aren't on the addendum
uh in respect of condition five it's to
add in a reference to the tetra tech
report with regard to the worst case
scenario reference in that condition
and with regards to condition six we're
just adding in words unless otherwise
approved in writing by the lpa so
subject to those
the recommendation is approval thank you
very much
i should have asked members that you
have seen the addendum and you have read
it okay for
items seven eight and nine sorry i
should have asked that
we have one public speaker rachel crick
who is the planning agent
good evening and again you've got five
minutes
and we'll let you know when it's a
minute to go thank you
good evening chair and members of the
committee i'm rachel crick a planning
director at averson young
we're pleased that officers are able to
provide strong support for this
application tonight
this reserve matters application
provides detail in relation to phase two
of the arterial part development in
respect of access appearance landscaping
layout and scale
consideration can only be given to the
acceptability of these details in the
determination of this application as the
principle of the industrial-led
development including the overall floor
space and building heights has already
been established through the 2018
outline permission
notwithstanding when compared to the
indicative proposals for phase 2 as
shown in that original permission
this scheme provides less floor space
lower building heights and substantially
more landscaping including a 15 meter
green buffer to the south of the site
this application follows on from phase
one of the original permission which has
already been delivered and is
operational
the level of demand for industrial here
in rayleigh is unprecedented and we
already have a number of occupiers
expressing interest in the proposed
industrial units
prior to submission of the application
we met with officers and councillors to
understand their views on the proposals
in response to comments received we have
provided additional sustainability
measures including rooftop solar panels
and increased briem rating from very
good to excellent
improved efficiency energy efficiency
measures and a commitment to low water
usage
following submission we've worked hard
to respond to representations received
by officers and statutory consultees as
a result the following changes have been
made
we've now incorporated a communal
amenity area benches and trees to ensure
that future employees have a high
quality outdoor area to enjoy during
their breaks
the proposed cycle store has been
consolidated to allow two-tier racks
allowing additional landscaping and
greening within the public realm
additional planting has been provided
along the southern boundary resulting in
improved benefits to biodiversity and
screening the access road has been
extended to the boundary of the adjacent
gypsy and traveller site and our client
has also agreed to plant a substantial
15 meter green buffer along the
boundaries of the site
the proposals will provide much needed
employment space which will not only
benefit rochefort district council but
also the wider south essex and thames
estuary growth area given the site's
close proximity to the thames free port
the lower thames crossing and south end
airport
if permission is granted work will start
immediately and is anticipated to be
completed by autumn 2023
allowing a number of key economic
benefits to come forward including the
delivery of approximately 800 new jobs
on the site along with other indirect
jobs associated with the development
comprising up to 1400 new jobs and
during the construction phase a direct
capital investment of around 30 million
pounds will be made and an estimated 54
million pounds of gross value added will
arise
the proposals will also lead to
increased business rates generated for
the council and increased local spending
in the district by future employees
which is estimated to be between 1.1
million and 2.4 million pounds per year
in conclusion the proposals will deliver
the following public benefits
the regeneration of an underutilized
heavily contaminated vacant and poor
quality area of scrub land which will be
reused decontaminated for employment-led
development that will meet future
employment needs of the district
a highly sustainable and modern
industrial facility that will provide
fit-for-purpose commercial units that
will enable local businesses to expand
or locate new businesses within the
district create a substantial number of
jobs for local people
result in significant capital investment
and wider economic benefits for the
district enhancements to biodiversity
and green inc and provide access
landscape and contamination improvements
on the adjacent site for potential
future residents
in addition no objections have been
received
letters of support have been submitted
and the proposals are strongly supported
by your planning officers who recognize
the importance of bringing forward the
next phase of this flagship development
as identified in paragraph 7.30 of the
committee report the proposed
development would deliver employment
uses in accordance with the outline
planning consent and adopted planning
policies including policy ne1 which
supports the employment land allocation
therefore i hope the committee will
support planning officer's
recommendation for refusal
um for approval and grant planning
permission for this application tonight
thank you
that's a freudian isn't it thank you
very much
thank you we have one more member with
us
tonight and that is councillor jack
lorman
would you like to say anything yeah you
have again you have five minutes thank
you
thank you chairman um
like most of most uh members here i've
been
involved in this right almost from the
start and i've known the history of this
area and we've had the opportunity to do
site visits
um i have to say
that um
left of the
bungalow is already another small
industrious state which so there's no
real impact
on anything along the air but i've been
quite impressed with the way this has
been managed and cooperated
and i have no issues with this at all
and i'd like to propose that this be
accepted
thank you very much
have you got a second up for mr lorman
uh can't scream
thank you members and we're now talking
on the motion for acceptance have we
anyone speak please
class race
and council foster we do counselors
first and then council foster
thank you chair um it was just a
concern
generally speaking i think this is a
good proposal but there is a concern
when we as a committee went to the site
one of the things that i think i can be
pretty sure that we were all shocked by
was the degree of contamination on this
particular area that we're talking about
here
talking to the site management who are
walking around with us they reckon that
the clearing of that contamination was
going to be in the millions
because of it being medical waste
now my concern is that although this is
covered on condition 10
um
does the
will the
report that is asked under condition 10
to be presented
to the council
give a
specific layout of where this
contamination is my concern is
that obviously it's on the gypsy and
traveller site as well
and during construction whether some of
that contamination may just be moved
over
and i'm not sure that the conditions
actually are clear enough on that
contamination at the moment
the cost implications to the council
should it be on the gypsier and traveler
site are big
so i think it would be wise to be
looking
at something that makes it that little
bit more clear in the conditions
sorry when can i talk to it i know
because if we if we say i'm afraid sorry
if if that is
if that is the recommendation is uh
accepted then that stops the debate
we can i will ask
um if we can ask
katie yeah
the condition that actually controls the
contamination and requires the developer
to thoroughly decontaminate that site to
a level that's acceptable
is on the outline consent
so when we granted outline when the
council granted outline planning consent
um
detailed
contamination
conditions were imposed
those have now been discharged in
relation to phase one so what the
developer has done is satisfied us that
um
they have obviously they've built that
out okay so they had to have
provided that detailed information and
that detailed report does does go into
that level of detail about the
contamination and where it is and where
the testing text takes place that has to
be done
so we have discharged the conditions in
relation to this part
then we'd expect those conditions to
similarly have will be discharged in
relation to the outline consent in
relation to the phase two part
looking at is where that actually goes
to my understanding from the site visit
is that it actually extends on to the
gypsy and traveller site the
contamination does um and so that um
if any development was ever going to
happen here then this site would also
need to be decontaminated but the
requirement on this developer is that in
order to
you know build um commercial units and
have them occupied they we have to be
satisfied that that site is
decontaminated to an acceptable level
okay then my question then is um is the
extent and the area that is covered by
the contamination that is on there which
is severe
is that actually mapped out
so as when the actual development
happens it's not moved over onto the
uh gypsy and travellers site do you
understand what i mean yeah i understand
it
there is the the decontamination
requirements are quite extensive
and we have our environmental health
look at those conditions and the the
information that comes in to discharge
those conditions in detail and often
that will require
off-site removal of specific types of
waste and we have they have to evidence
that so as part of the reports that are
submitted to us we have evidence of the
off-site if you like removal of of waste
so i think we're happy that the the the
deep the contamination conditions that
are on the outline are standard wording
if you like um so they apply we apply
them to lots of different sites and
we're quite satisfied that they
thoroughly cover
the requirements okay thank you your
indulgence chairman thank you very much
councillor foster
chairman
points
one question
the road
uh abuts the gypsy and traveller site is
that in effect a public road and if and
when that site gets developed will the
gypsies and travelers have the right to
use it to access that site
and the second question is on uh
page 7.25
item 5.1
ecc raised some concerns about what the
subject urban design and missed
opportunities for landscaping
so do the landscaping proposals that
have been presented
address the ecc issues
the requirement we can require of the
developer is that the actual road
surface is
okay yeah
the road surface is actually provided
all the way up to uh butting essentially
the gypsy and traveller site allocation
it is then for future
it's not for planning essentially to
require that to be
anything other than just a surface road
all the way up i don't there isn't an
intention i don't think for the road
within the site to be adopted by essex
county councillors
highway authorities an adopted road so
it would be for any future
developer of the gypsy and traveller
site to
consider
rights of access over that road to if
that were to be the access that was
going to
be used
yes you can
if that site is developed i understand
it's not going to be an essex adopted
road
but can we make a condition that that
road would be allowed to be used by
the gypsy and traveller community that
would be
using that site
and we we have thought through uh the
implications of this application for
future development of the gypsy and
traveler site allocation and we're
satisfied that we've gone as far as we
we can in terms of planning and that
requirement that the actual surface is
provided and we don't say for instance
have a building here that you know would
prohibit
um a vehicular access being provided
through to the gypsy and travel
allocation
that's as far as we can go
it is then for any future developer
um to have discussions with adjoining
site owners or through a compulsory
purchase process to
get a right of access if this is the
access that would be used for the gypsy
and travel allocation um
i go i don't think it's completely
unobtainable for another potential
access through to that site to be
an option
but certainly what we've secured through
requiring
the road surface to extend all the way
down here is another possible option so
there is one possible future option of
access through to that site
sorry you did have another question
though
yeah the second question was another
question um has the landscaping address
the essex concerns about the urban
design as they headlined it
could you just point me to that page
number again please yeah
it's page 7.25 5.1
yes
so certainly what we have done is
responded to essex county council in
terms of their suggestion that
that this site really should facilitate
some sort of outdoor amenity space
seating space for employees because
there's going to be you know a fair
number of employees on the site and so
what we have done is secured this area
of seating um
adjacent to here and i think
um the other aspect was
to do with tree planting
i think and what i haven't shown you
tonight but i mean i did show you the
landscaping layout plan
so this gives
this doesn't give detail but what we do
have also is a very detailed landscaping
plan showing where trees are going to be
planted within the street so i think
that has sufficiently addressed their
concerns and certainly officers are
satisfied that there's enough
soft landscaping within the site and
including significant amount of tree
planting
thank you
council stanley please
thank you chairman um i just want to ask
about the
lighting levels as they're going to be
four meters
on the uh
wall
adjacent to
uh amwood lodge um where the i presume
that the fence line will only be two
meters high
can i stop you where are you referring
to in here please i'm sorry
7.24 thank you
4.73
and 4.74
light lighting levels yeah thank you
sorry uh generally no no no problem um
yeah um
yeah um yeah about the fence at the
height of the fence there
uh because those light those lights
especially leds as you very well know
now they can produce quite a lot of
light and are they screened so that the
light that light doesn't intrude into
the back garden of the amwood lodge
thank you
what we have submitted and i haven't
shown you tonight but is a very detailed
lighting plan
with all the details
of the specific lights and the types
that are going to be provided and what
they've done an assessment in terms of
how that light spill
would would be generated
we've had our environmental health
officer look at that
and i've gone back and actually
questioned it again just to make sure
we're satisfied so there are going to be
if you can see the light pen um there
are going to be a number of light
attached to um this southern elevation
of unit 10
but they the environmental health of has
no concerns that the type of light they
are and the level of light that will be
emitted from them would in any way cause
harm to the to a residential amenity of
the occupiers of anward lodge in
addition there are lights on columns
that are going to light up this service
yard to unit 10 so here
and again they're going to be
on columns and mounted but the lights so
directional
that essentially they look like modern
street lights from a distance if you
like so
we are completely satisfied that there
won't be light spill that will be
harmful to this the occupiers of that
property yeah
thank you very much
are there any other members wishing to
speak please
no
members there's a motion on the table to
for approval can i please have a show of
hands for approval please keep them up
until
it's
unanimous thank you members
members up item is unanimous thank you
item
eight is the the dell madrid w rayleigh
and mike strengths will
um
present this officer's report thank you
mike
this application is one of two
applications you'll see tonight that
were originally delegated but in the
time taken to deal with the application
the applicant has since been elected and
you'll be familiar that when it's to
deal with a
member of staff or a member then it has
to come
before this committee in the interests
of openness
um
the application site is lane is is off
the screen but to the to the south there
and there's a long entrance road down to
this collection of buildings some former
stables with actually permission for
residential use there and as an annex
building type use here we're talking
about this largest of the sites which is
the main bungalow on the site
if we could switch to plan two please
um
the building there's a plan of the
existing building
which uh the original i think element is
in this part but you'll see there's
extensive flat roofing at the back and i
think you'll see from the report that uh
the the it's in various stages of repair
some of it leaking i believe
structurally unsound or whatever so what
the applicant is doing if we could jump
to three please
they're not enlarging the building not
in terms of floor space which your
policy looks at but they're roofing over
the unsightly flat roof elements
so there's no increase in floor space
there's some internal works that are
being shown in blue but they don't
interest us that's just a revised layout
in the use of the building but they're
taking the shell if you like of the
building and they're putting over that
a new roof and
cladding material on the outside
there would be because you're spanning
over the roof there would be an increase
in height of 0.81 meters to the main
part and up to
5.49 meters on the rear part
if we could jump to the plan image
here we see an artist's impression of
the resulting building you'll see a very
modern design take as opposed to the
sort of dated flat roofed
and render appearance of the building
um that we have there
in greenbelt terms your policy says that
you'd encourage good design and it
whether a building isn't is appropriate
or not or an extension is appropriate is
based on your floor space so as the
applicant here is not increasing the
floor space it's not inappropriate and
although there is an increase in height
officers take the view that the
enhancement of design
offsets any harm to the openness by the
virtue of a slight increase in height
on the addendum you'll see
a letter from the applicant that sets
out
some circumstances because of the delay
and because of that i believe they're in
tenanted housing at the moment and
builders are good to go because of the
further delay they've had to make a
start but they've only started conscious
of members decision and interest they've
only started on works that are internal
that don't by themselves require
planning permission
so um as i say it's appropriate
development in the green belt it's a
better design
and uh officers are recommending that
you approve the application subject to
the conditions set out in the report
thank you very much we've got no
speakers the world member is uh
councillor stanley
yes just swiping its council standing
thank you chairman um
got nothing to do with well it is to do
with the property
i just wondered if uh has there been any
uh bat
occupation uh on the site
and should there be
some consideration to the wildlife in
the way of
uh a bat or or something like you know
whatever may be
uh considered to be
roosting if you like or whatever you
like to call it on the site please
um all applicants that deal with uh
substantial alterations to the building
have to
sign what we call a bat declaration it's
a bit like a checklist
it asks a number of criteria
which is really
that the decision you take as members
isn't harmful to bats we've formulated
this checklist with natural england and
the idea being that you've been
diligent in making sure that for the
purpose of the decision we as a council
have to take
that you've covered whether there's a
risk to bats or not so it asks for
things like the condition of the roofing
availability of waterscapes nearest
trees so forth the bats use as migratory
utes and feeding areas
but the main responsibility and burden
is upon the applicant so
there's been many a perhaps bat survey
or even a bat declaration that perhaps
has said no there's no signs of bat no
soiling of cracks in the walls or
anything like that giving away that the
bats may be present but when they start
pulling the building about they suddenly
find they've got roosting bats well
that's then the responsibility of the
person doing the works and perhaps their
contractors to notify people
specialist agencies yes we've got bats
and what do we do about it
so i'm not ruling out that bats would
never be present but from the point of
view of the process we're engaged with
we've gone as far as we need to to
rehearse whether it's essential that a
bat survey has been done or whether
given the answers to the bat deck it's
okay for members to proceed to a
decision but i can't promise you where
the bats would be there are not
interestingly the bat people without
giving you a mini bat lecture they say
the bats float around different sites so
they have maternal roots they go to cool
houses when it's hot like now and they
go to warm houses when it's
when it's cold
so you could survey and find there's no
bats and then when the work is done in a
different season you find there are bats
so you can never quite rule it out but i
think members can be uh assured that
from the point of view of the decision
that you've taken there is no risk we've
gone far enough as we need to to
ascertain whether the bats could be
present or not and in this case there's
no evidence that they are and
and if you look on page 8.4 5.7 the
proposals are considered likely to have
any significant impact on bats for
wildlife
sorry i did yeah
that's the reason why i brought that up
thank you are there any other members
that would like to
counsel mr mason
thank you chair
um two points i'd like um
expansion and clarity on
one on page 8.3 4.5 it states quite
clearly the site is located within the
metropolitan greenbelt where national
policy allows the extension of an
existing building provided it does not
result in a disproportionate addition
over above the size of the original
building now i accept that the floor
space is the same as what is there now
but nowhere in the report and i may have
missed it so i've apologized if i have
does it tell us what the original size
was before as the report says as it has
been significantly already extended
so
i'm not sure
what the original building was because
that's where you would obviously base
your floor space your original floor
space
so have we got that information or is it
not available
thank you
the original building from what i recall
is somewhere about here okay
and members are right if we was dealing
with a proposed extension of the
building in floor space your dm17
asks us to
calculate the original floor space and
you allow up to 25 increase
this property has been extended in a
number of ways mostly i think through
permitted development rights okay so i'm
pretty sure it's had its 25
yeah but this is different because
there's no floor space increase this is
the same shell i don't know if we can
shove up the floor space of the existing
plant this is the same box as it were
but all they're doing is roofing over
and cladding the outside so so the issue
for if we see the floor plan as a
comparison that's possible
the the issue for members in terms of
size increase is not one of floor space
it's one of uh the roof height and and
because you're
what we're trading off is the unsightly
flat roofed editions particularly at the
back
yeah which you know we'd love to be able
to get rid of those but permitted
development rights sort of encourage
that we're getting rid of this
unsightliness at the back
yeah
the casualty of that perhaps is that
there's an increasing height of like 0.8
of a meter on the main ridge but what
we're actually getting is a better
looking building in terms of the ratio
of walling to roof massing which
architecturally is better to look at
so
there's always a trade-off with these
things
it's not inappropriate development
because there's no floor space increase
if they've been proposing another
extension it would have been recommended
for refusal because it's already had a
25 but because they're working with what
they've got
what this application is doing is
raising the roof and spanning over that
that footprint
so so that's why there's no floor space
calculation because there doesn't need
to be one
if i could just ask
for a further point on that so
presumably there would be no more
permitted development rights on on this
plot once and i agree that it is
betterment of the site but
i'm concerned that it seems to have
grown
like topsy it's gone
about four times the original size by
the looks of it
so would there be further permitted
development rights possible on this or
are they going to be
rescinded
chairman thank you
i think
if the original building is roughly this
part i think there would be the
potential to do some extension on the
side the the thing is over the years
permitted rights have changed from sort
of given volume to now since um
20
i think 2008 something like that
they've been able to extend by half the
width one direction then half the width
in the other direction if the plot
allows and then um this is unusual
because this has got no immediate
neighbours and you can do a special
eight meter deep extension at ground
floor so the current rights that the
government give that's also remember
they're allowing now for bungalows to be
converted to houses subject to no
neighbor objection in certain
circumstances of the age of the building
so permitted development rights are
quite generous now this still has those
permitted development rights so there's
at least the possibility of a little
extension on the side but i think this
is the boundary so they won't be able to
go too far
but there may be other possibilities
you've got another one if we show the
front
if we can show the site plan sorry
where you have sites
members will be familiar that a lot of
front walls anything in the front
requires planning permission but where
you have a site
that is behind land if you like it's um
i forget the name of the the term
landlocked or whatever you can
potentially do
an unlimited front extension as far as
the plot allows
so permitted development rights in a
rural location sometimes can be very
very generous
okay thank you i think that
clarifies that for everyone and my
second point is just a small one um i
assume that the plot and the garden
there there is reference to the garden
size but the garden is still classified
uh metropolitan green belt
yes the
is green belt you don't have like
because it's a residential plot that
that's not green belt it's not
like that
but when you're working in the green
belt from a planning application point
of view
there are certain things you have to
take account the fact that dwellings
already exist so then that takes you
down a certain route where you've got
existing buildings that takes you down
another route so
um
the sea of greenbelt sweeps over this
area of land the building everything is
all located in the green belt but as we
discussed in answer to the earlier
question there are certain rights for
whatever's going on in the green belt
depending on how generous the government
wants to be with its pd
thank you thank you
are there any other members
there's a record i'll
do a recommendation from the chair for
approval can i have a second to please
ian foster council sorry council foster
sorry
members can i have a show of hands for
approval please
members that's unanimous thank you i've
just been asked by an a member of this
committee to have a five minute comfort
break
before we move on to the next item okay
so please come back within five minutes
thank you
thank you um the second item i won't
bother re-uh
saying the the location i think members
are remember this this application if we
jump to the second plan please
um
is for an out building located over here
in in this corner of the site
you'll see a simple structure
rectangular plan it's got a sedan roof
on or sedum roof on the top actually
planted some thought given into the
design same materials as with the
building
and it faces into the site
but built slightly differently members
are interested um 0.2 of a meter 20
centimeters lower
and seven and a half centimeters lower
ease it could be built permitted
development if
two meters from the boundary this is a
meter from the boundary of the site so
um by virtue of some slight size changes
this application is necessary
but we don't count the outbuildings in
the floor space
contribution to appropriateness
equally we'd rarely count the loss of
the buildings in the same way because
they can quite often be built permitted
development so it's a small building in
a large site
um
it's ancillary to the uh the use of the
site i think it's got down there's an
art studio or something but it can be
put to any any domestic use
and is recommended for approval
thank you very much
are there any visiting members who would
like to speak on this
nope just don't reply
councillor stanley
would you like to say anything
just please yeah five minutes mr stanley
councillor stanley sorry as per usual
thank you um just to ask the
officer um
it's been just been designated for an
art studio and nothing else not any
residential or anything like that
thank you
thank you mike sorry
been used for residential particularly
in independent dwelling then that would
require planning permission but
they've said that they want to use it
for an art studio but
in the life of the building could become
a garden shared
small pool children's program anything
to do with the domestic use of the house
members anyone else would like to ask
any questions on this
as i recommend i'll do from the chair
there's a recommendation for approval
can i have a second to please
counselor foster
all in favor
that is unanimous thank you members
unanimous for item nine thank you
members item 10.
bear with me i've got to get my papers
this is a agenda item 10 19 south street
now katie fowler will present the
officer's report
thank you chairman
uh so the applications are for both very
a variation of condition and listed
building consent just for the point of
views and just doing them as one
presentation
um the site is located on the southern
approach to the centre of rochford and
within rochford town center boundary and
the conservation area the application
building was a grade two former house
with a number of outbuildings and an
area of outstand of hard standing the
building was formerly used by virtual
district council's offices but this uses
ceased during covert 19.
the applications for amendments to an
extent planning application
18 stroke
00282 stroke fpl which permitted the
change of use of number 19 style street
to create seven one bedroom flats
um the amendments
include addition of air brick grills to
the existing external rear and north
elevations in lieu of the consented
ventilation grills and gas boiler flues
and so you can see on the plans here the
left hand elevations here are the ones
that were approved previously
sorry they're the existing ones the ones
in the middle the ones that were
approved by that 2018 consent and then
the ones on the right hand side here are
the ones uh proposed
um and then if i move to plan three we
have the also the addition of a
conservation style roof light to the
center so if i just zoom in here
it's this roof light here which is
proposed
and this would serve the common
stairwell there's also the addition of
ventilation terminals to the
roof area which are these ones pointed
out here so the roof lights along this
elevation um were permitted by the 2018
consent
then finally the amendments relate to
the removal of some of
the ceiling to allow for light tunnels
to the roof lights
as well as the ceiling height raised in
the second bay of and out of the
outbuilding which is attached to number
19.
the amendments are required to allow for
the delivery of the scheme in accordance
with building regulations
in terms of the harm the insertion of
the roof light would necessitate the
removal of areas of roof timbers and
slates some of these being originally
historic their air brick grills would be
inserted and coursed into existing brick
work requiring the removal of two to
three existing bricks in each instance
the ventilation terminals and vaulting
of the ceiling would result in some
minor loss of materials
while some noise for historic fabric
would occur it has been kept to a
minimum and has been considered
acceptable by the specialist listed
building advisor the roof lights and
vents would be located on the inside of
the dual pitch roof are not visible from
the public room if i just go on to the
roof plan again you can see that these
are the dual pitched roof bits here and
they're both located in the inside so
not visible from the rear
or the wider sides
the proposed grills would be closely
matched in character and color to the
existing brickworks and mortar and the
details of these have been recommended
as a condition
overall the proposal was not considered
to result in harm to the significance of
the heritage assets as the development
is an amendment to the original planning
commission the application does not need
to consider a further impact on
residential amenity garden amenities
spaces parking trees and ecology or any
other matter that was a material
consideration within the approved
planning consent
as the full planning application is a
variation of condition is recommended
that all conditions are carried over
with the exception of condition one
which relates to time limits as a
technical start has been made on the
original planning application
condition two would have the drawing
substituted and condition three part d
would be amended to read as a compliance
condition for the window detail which
has been agreed as part of a discharge
condition application and just to be
clear the listed building consent will
have all new conditions as that one is
impossible to be varied so it is only
the full application which would be
varied
in addition chairman is requested that
an additional two story two conditions
are imposed following correspondence
from essex county council specialist
archaeology officer
the archaeology officer has stated that
they were not consulted on the original
planning consent but consider it
important for the building record the
conditions are applied these conditions
would read as follows
no demolitional conversion work of any
kind shall take place into a programme
of archaeological investigation has been
secured in accordance with a written
scheme of investigation which has been
submitted by the applicant and improved
in writing by the local plan authority
and no demolition or conversion works of
any kind shall take place until the
completion of the programme of
archaeological investigation identified
in the written scheme of investigation
defined in the condition above but we'll
have to condition it depending on the
number but that will vary between listed
building consent and full
and therefore the application is
recommended for approval subject to the
conditions that well set out in the
report and the inclusion of the two
extra conditions raided by officers
within this presentation
thank you thank you very much there's a
visiting member councillor jim goodin do
would you like to speak on this
no other visiting uh councillors
no
thank you
uh the other walk now we'll go back into
the committee the world council is uh
after council arthur williams have you
any comment on this please
no
uh anyone else uh councillor stanley
um
just one thing that uh
will the
uh roof
lights if you like to call them or
whatever
in this towards the buildings um
will they have uh
fire
uh emergencies on them should the should
there be a fire and and
will they open up or will they stay
closed
uh automatic
some premises do have automatic openings
so that the smoke can get out get away
rather than in the property itself uh
i'm just asking that and also with the
gas terminals that the uh
for the central eating are the exhaust
pipes anywhere near
windows and
they should be away from windows
especially
or above windows should i say but not
if you've got windows
for first and second floor they should
be away from the windows yeah
thank you thank you
uh
is when you're saying about the
roof lights do you mean these ones here
that on this roof or the ones along this
on the out buildings
right so the roof lights here i'm not
sure about because they were approved as
part of the 2018 consent
uh so i don't know whether they would be
the automatic opening vents which would
allow for the escape during the fire but
i believe that the windows
on the building allowed for
evacuation in that circumstance
in terms of this vent here this would be
an aov so i believe that one would allow
for escape during the case of a fire
and then with the gas terminals i'll go
back to the elevation plan
i don't believe that any of them are
actually exhaust
pipes on the elevation so there wouldn't
be any by
any windows directly
and it would it's more building
regulations matters so they would
consider that rather than planning
okay
thank
moving this from the chair to
approve
so have uh show of hands for approval oh
second first please
leslie butcher
and a show of hands for approval please
sorry
that's unanimous members
we're not having a presentation on this
members i've just been advised
so as um
coaches have already done it so again
councillor
james gooding
do would you like to speak on this sorry
any other visiting members
nope
uh council from the chair councillor
williams no does anyone want to make
any item no i'll recommend from the
chair that we approve this can i have a
secondary daniel councillor fd
members can have a show of hands please
to have this approved
it's unanimous thank you members i will
close now close this meeting at 2052
thank you very much for attending and a
good meeting thank you